here's a two-part question who are you
supporting for the 2020 Democratic
nomination and do you actually like that
person there's a really interesting new
likability poll from Quinnipiac
University that people have been
emailing me about and asking me to
comment on and to summarize the results
of this Quinnipiac poll on Democratic
candidate likability every single
candidate has a net dislike a what are
called net unfavorable rating other than
Joe Biden who isn't even actually a 2020
candidate as of right now now by the way
please don't write to me angrily about
what I'm telling you here I'm just the
messenger I'm not saying anything
positive or negative about Joe Biden or
any of the other candidates here I'm
just discussing the poll results with
you before I start getting angry
messages about this the measure the
metric is called net net favorability if
more people have a favorable rather than
unfavorable view of you that's called
net favorability if more people dislike
you it's called net unfavorability so
let's look at the results for the
Democratic candidates among all voters
and then among Democrats you will notice
that among all voters Joe Biden has a
plus 14 likability ratio whereas every
other Democratic candidate Booker not
everybody's included in this poll but
the ones that are Booker Gillibrand
Harris Hickenlooper Inslee Klobuchar or
Roark Sanders and Warren have anywhere
from a minus four to a minus eighteen
favorability net favorability rating now
I'm going to come back to that in a
second on the Democratic side you will
notice if you look just among Democrats
everybody but jay Inslee has at least
some net favorability Joe Biden would
the highest net favorability followed by
Kamala Harris then Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders and beto Aurora but let's
go back again because we're thinking now
in terms of the general election if you
look at the net unfavorability among all
voters of most of these candidates
you will notice is that a lot of these
candidates aren't really very well-known
so when you look at Amy Klobuchar for
example she has an 11th 11 percent
favorable 16 percent unfavorable that
gets her minus 5 most people haven't
even heard of Amy Klobuchar so what we
are seeing right now I believe Pat is
that this is an artifact of lack of name
recognition the more well-known a
candidate is right now the more negative
their favorability is other than Joe
Biden who again isn't even a candidate
right now so my prediction is that these
numbers are simply too early to tell us
very much about who is actually likable
on the Democratic side that may
certainly be true the Bernie Sanders won
at least at this stage is surprising to
me because I always thought that
Republicans and people who disagree with
Bernie on policy still view him
favorably because they think of them as
honest maybe maybe or maybe not the
other thing I thought of is that I think
you're seeing so much unfavorability
because you're mixing in both
Republicans and people who are on the
right with people who are on the left
but don't support one particular
candidate so like if you ask me if I
have a favorable view of Amy Klobuchar
or beta or auric or cory booker some of
these corporatist democrats i may say no
and that pulls moon with the republicans
too so overall you're going to have this
net unfavorability i think that's what
it is at this stage but of course if you
get to the general election and it's
Klobuchar versus Trump or Booker versus
Trump I'm gonna go with the Democrat
that's an interesting point which is
that Republicans just don't like any of
these people if they've heard of them
whereas Democrats who may be more
familiar with them are actually taking a
more nuanced view based on who they're
likely to support in a primary even if
they'd vote for any or almost any of
these candidates if they were to be the
nominees the Joe Biden thing I think
Biden's benefiting from being remembered
sort of favorably from the Obama
presidency particularly in contrast to
the Trump administration the sort of
affable sidekick to Barack Obama it's
not I believed that Biden is seen as a
progressive leader particularly since
he's pretty moderate on
issues but for the for the time being I
would not read too much into this
Biden is up but other people are liked
by Democrats and in the immediate what
we need to figure out is who's going to
be the Democratic nominee eventually yes
you're going to need some Democratic
challenger to trump
that's not acutely disliked just being
disliked a little less than Trump is
probably not going to be enough to win
especially when half the country doesn't
vote but I wouldn't read too much into
these numbers for the time being make
sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show
while you're there follow me
at David Pakman we will take a break
speaking of Bernie Sanders Ben Cohen of
Ben and Jerry's Fame joins me next to
talk about the Bernie Sanders candidacy
and being a national co-chair for Bernie
and will talk about some of the cases
being made against Bernie this time
around that's coming up after the break
when you buy one of those variety packs
of socks there's bound to be one pair
that you don't really like as much as
the rest
but with dollar sock crew you can build
your own package of socks starting as
low as a dollar sixty a pair and choose
from classic patterns or quirky vibrant
designs shop dollar sock crew calm now
and receive 30% off your first order
with the code Pakman that's dollar sock
crew calm code
PA que ma N